Hello Freak bitches.
And,
and interestingly after that,
the way I dealt with coming out was I
would tell someone and then I would get
this little burst of feeling better.
I would suddenly cause you,
I was like constricting my heart.
And when I would tell someone it would,
it would open up a little and I'd feel
better and I could,
I really could feel like I could breathe
better,
like really felt better.
And then I would wait until that
pressure would start building again.
Sometimes I would wait months and then I
would tell someone and then I would do
this over the course of like two years.
And then eventually I realized,
I was like,
you know,
every time I tell somebody this thing
that I think is horrible and they're
pretty much okay and I feel better,
I was like,
I got to end this,
it's time to end this now.
And that's,
that's basically when I told the
remaining people.
And um,
that was it.
It's a weird secret because the people
that do care that don't like it,
they're not worth knowing.
And nobody,
literally nobody,
nobody that I told,
you know,
my dad struggled for a little bit or you
know,
whatever.
This and that.
My a lot,
the thing that mostly people got was
that nobody believed I was gay.
That was like my mate.
Did you play basketball?
You play basketball,
you know,
like that.
So nobody could believe like they just,
well you don't seem gay.
Like I don't like to dance.
I don't ks dancing.
I learned my dancing from cosby.
Like that's my move,
you know?
So all of that like,
so that was the main thing.
Everyone was just sideswiped.
So a lot of times people will say to me,
you know,
you're,
you act straight or you're straight
acting or saying,
which in the gay community has thought
of,
it's like this great thing,
you know,
they're,
if you're straight acting your
masculine,
it's really great.
But I don't,
I don't take it that way because every
time someone says it to me,
it makes me feel like a freak.
You know what I mean?
Like why am I,
yeah,
because I am who I am.
This is it.
You know what I mean?
Like,
like I had gay sex last night after I
had that grass fed beef,
you know?
And so I'm gay.
I'm married to a guy there.
It sounds like a gay person,
but that's a pretty gay married to a
guy.
I would say.
Again,
that's pretty gay.
That's what I realized.
I was like,
Oh,
I'm marrying this dude.
Like I guess,
but you know what I mean?
Like I was like,
Holy Shit.
Like I guess,
well,
you know,
turn it back now.
Yeah.
Um,
it was a phase.
Yeah,
this is a long face.
I'm really like,
you know,
it's dragging out this phase thing.
But I realized that,
that if I felt better when I told people
that,
that there had to be some value in that
in a way that I couldn't understand
things.
Right.
But to the,
to the straight acting like I don't,
it means nothing to me when I meet guys
that are completely flaming or if I meet
guys that are that you'd have no idea.
Like I like people based on their values
and their sense of humor and like shit
like that.
I never asked to wall people that matter
as as yeah.
And you know what,
that sort of a great way to bring this
all around because that gets away from
judging people on what you're supposed
to think about them and all that social
justice warrior and regressive bullshit
versus judging people on the content of
their character.
It was the highlight of my,
uh,
training as a person.
There was,
um,
training George for those two weeks and
the first three days that I was with
him,
it was so mind blowing that how famous
he was.
People were coming up,
morning taken photos we were eating.
And then after the third day,
fourth day fee,
then you realize this thing,
this,
the machine doesn't turn off.
And then,
um,
he can't go to the chemist to buy
shampoo.
He can't just,
uh,
let's call
called the cameras.
Like,
where the fuck are you getting your
champion?
He might go,
he might go into the toilets to pass
stool and you got people waiting at the
side of the cubicle to wait to get a
photo with him.
So He's,
and then we've got to,
every time we went somewhere,
I'd always have to be through the VIP
entrance.
He couldn't walked through the front
door,
uh,
especially in Montreal.
So one time we went to a nightclub and
then we've got an in through the VIP and
then we'll,
we'll walk into our,
uh,
our table and then we're about maybe 15
feet from their table and someone said,
Jews Birger as p.
And we had a word of a lie.
The whole dance floor stopped dancing.
Everyone's looked at us turn and the
whole club's walk towards that table.
And,
um,
without losing a beat,
we've turned straight back around and
walked straight back out and like club
because,
uh,
it was like a tsunami of fans that had
just come into real sit down.
He said,
oh,
we'll come back here in a couple of
years later when the,
when the distracted,
um,
I can't come in right now because it's
like this every day is,
this doesn't,
yeah,
this is,
this is normal.
And he's,
he has,
he's a good friends that he's our age,
body guards that stand around in the
whole time because,
uh,
people say,
can I get a photo?
And the body guys will step in and say,
oh no,
no,
flashy.
As soon as the flash goes off,
then the whole club's going to come.
And then George will say yes.
And then the body goes,
oh,
sorry.
Harbor George says,
look,
you don't understand if the camera goes
in,
we've got a problem and everybody's want
photo essay in end.
Even at a red light,
we're driving in the car.
Me and George got the radio on,
big jar.
We stopped,
we stopped at a red light and all you
hear is GSP,
GSP and four tees credit,
a champion.
He is,
he always looks way smalls and then
certainly just juice for just a
fraction,
just so he's had our eyesight of,
of,
of the fans.
But it's,
um,
but that's everyone.
Every single,
he'd rather from your car park even he'd
catch a taxi from the front gate to the
back gate because it from walking a
hundred feet would be a half an hour.
Um,
would photos and handshakes and high
fives.
And
I was doing this,
uh,
this film project thing in Alaska and I
tracked down this guy that killed the
Kodiak bear with a knife.
Buck knife.
What?
Yeah,
it was crazy story.
Old older guy too.
His name was Jeanne Moe.
There's been a ton of articles written
about it and like outdoor life.
And if this was back,
it wasn't that long ago,
but I can't really put the knife in a
musket.
I mean you're these bear stories and I
was just like,
I'm going to tracking down some of these
barriers during this bears darker and so
he's on Kodiak island.
Kodiak Brown bears are the biggest bears
in the world,
but they don't,
there's not that many attacks,
surprisingly for the size of the bear
and the many there are.
But there's probably also,
there's also not,
Kodiak island isn't like yellowstone
park.
I mean you don't have that many people
are really,
so he's getting out of deer turns around
the Baird's just on him,
all he has is the knife,
so he's like trying to fight it off,
stabbing the thing and the bear like
territory piece out of his arm,
out of his leg,
picks him up,
is shaking them around.
Then the bear goes off and it one point
he just like thought he was done.
He's like yelling at the bear,
bear comes back mauls him another time
you stab it and fighting it off and then
I guess he stabbed it enough times.
He kept like trying to feed his arm
whilst just like he said he was out of
strength.
I think the bear when officer like laid
down was bleeding out.
He might've crawled to his rifle at that
point.
I think he,
I can't remember if the bear was dead or
not,
but he shot it after the bear was just
like laying there and then hikes,
you know,
three,
four miles back to the beach and he's
like,
ah,
I can't remember how old he was.
He had [inaudible] 60,
something like that.
I remember this story.
Yeah,
he was a,
and then he says,
so then his son,
they me to son,
they take them to this.
There's one cab in there where there's
year round residents and uh,
it was actually on I think raspberry
island there and they bring them into
this cabin and there was a German couple
that lives there and like he said,
they,
they brought him in the cabin and for
some reason I cannot remember exactly
why,
but the dude that owned the cabin ended
up taking a chainsaw and cutting out the
wall so the rescuers could come in and
get a stretcher in like stabilize him
cause he's just dying on the table and
they take him to Kodiak hospital,
do all the surgeries,
skin grafts,
everything's saved.
His life ended up getting,
keeping like you end up buying the
bareback at an auction and uh,
they may like a rug thing.
Oh Huh.
I mean that's why the the Romans,
I mean when they were feeding the lions
are Christians.
Right.
That's what that was all bout.
It's like to see how long that guy can
last in there just to get her Saudi or
release at ours.
Check this out.
This is like,
that's the story that I did not know
about.
So what though it up,
it was after day.
Would the have the beastie their fight
each other or they'll dive the lie on
seat Cristianos or something than a
typical thing is that after the end of
the day when a whole bunch of these
animals have been killed in one fight or
another,
the Roman emperors to kind of look cool
and popular with the crowds who then
distribute the meat to all the poor
people of Rome.
So all the animals killed India in,
I would then be eaten by all the poorest
people in Rome as a Freebie because you
are a poor person and you're more likely
than not.
A lot of people in a room,
we're pretty close to starving a lot of
the times.
Nothing.
Get them be thrown away.
You eat scene,
right?
You eat the whole,
whatever they give you,
you eat it.
So what does that mean?
That means that among other things,
they would end up as weird exotic dish
in on the on Arrow one table.
Sometime you get also the interiors of
animals that have just been eating
people.
So through via second hand,
you're also eating people cc or eating
stomach contents of a lie on that just
got killed.
India,
INA and ally on just finish feeding on a
Christie and so you're having a Lion
Christiane Burger for yourself.
[inaudible].